لا أعرف حقًا ما الذي يحدث
لك ، أعلم أنه مجرد يوم حزين لنا
جميعًا اليوم وقد
عرفنا جميعًا ملكة واحدة فقط
إنها شخص كنا دائمًا نتطلع
إليه لنفسي
إنه مجرد يوم حزين
إنه يوم  يوم حزين للغاية ،
أنا لست ملكًا لم أكن أبدًا ملكًا ،
لذلك لا أعرف لماذا تأثرت
به كثيرًا ، اكتشفت حرفيًا
قبل بضع دقائق فقط وقبل حدوثه
لم أكن أعتقد أنني سأفعل  كن
لكنني حقًا وأدركت مدى أهميتها
التي تعرفها
لعدم الاستقرار ولكن أه
وقد تحملت الكثير
خلال العام الماضي ، يجب أن أقول إنها
تتعامل مع الأمور بشكل
جيد وأعتقد أنك تعلم أن تشارلز سيقع
فيها  خطىها
لهذا السبب أعتقد أنني أقوم بعمل جيد ،
إنها مجرد شخص رائع
كان والداي يحترمانها كثيرًا
وقد تعهدت بحياتها لهذا البلد
وسمحت لها بالدخول إلى هذا البلد بإحترام كبير
وواجب واحترام
وشرف وأنا لا أفعل ذلك.  لا أعرف ما إذا كان هذا سيكون
ميكرو آخر أم
لا  كن غريبًا
لأنك فقط
تعرف أننا في أوائل العشرينات من العمر
كما تعلمون أن هذا هو كل
ما عرفناه ، لذا فهذه
نهاية هذا العقد تنتهي بكل
ما عرفناه ونأتي إلى
هذا الجديد
إنه حقبة جديدة بالنسبة لنا مثل أننا
لم نعرف سوى الملكة الواحدة والآن
نحن ننتقل إلى شاشة جديدة